no tiene ninguna intención de cambiar la
política de su gobierno en materia
migratoria Este es esencialmente el
principal punto es de la rueda de prensa
en la cual la nueva jefa del gobierno
italiano reiteró este viernes la línea
dura del ejecutivo ultraderechista de
Italia meloni condenó la decisión del
gobierno de Francia de suspender El
acuerdo que preveía la acogida de 3.500
refugiados actualmente en Italia una
reacción incomprensible e injustificada
dijo melón y Italia no puede ser el
único país a cargo de todos los
inmigrantes que atraviesan el
Mediterráneo afirmó melón y quien
recordó que desde el inicio del año
Italia ha cogido casi 90.000 inmigrantes
mientras que Francia ha aceptado
solamente a 38 refugiados en el marco
del pacto europeo de redistribución de
refugiados melón y reclamó el
establecimiento de un mecanismo
automático para la redistribución de los
refugiados a distintos estados miembros
de la Unión Europea y pidió a Europa que
negocié acuerdos directamente con los
países del norte del África para
bloquear los barcos de las redes de
tráfico de ese de seres humanos antes de
que zarpen para intentar esta peligrosa
travesía en el mar Mediterráneo en la
cual cada año cientos de inmigrantes
mueren ahogados